the digital age influenced our company
in three different ways first of all it
provided us with opportunity we finance
technology so thanks to the digital age
we took part in the giant boom I would
say the digital age has fueled our
revenue growth in large measure probably
more importantly though it's enabled us
to get a lot more done we accomplish
several times as much as we used to
simply because technology has enabled us
to become so much more efficient but
finally technology has taken away a lot
of the mundane chores resulting in our
having time to provide greater value to
our clients than we were able to do in
the past and of course that really makes
our jobs much more enjoyable and our
clients a lot happier
Oh